[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها بالعناوين
مؤتمر شرم الشيخ للمناخ ينطلق تاكيد على
الحلول العاجله والبعد في وجهه التغيرات
المناخيه
يومان تفصل الولايات المتحده عن الاقتراع
النسبي الناخبين على التصويت بكثافه
جدلا واسع حول جامعه سودانيه وهميه وضبط
شهادات مزيفه في تخصصات صحيه في السعوديه
في الرابعه
رابعه تتجول في لازم يجمع اكثر من 50 شركه
عالميه واقليميه غالبيتها صحي
شركات كوريا الجنوبيه تبدا جوله في الرياض
لبحث الفرص الاستثماريه في النقل الابتكار
نبدا من شرم الشيخ حيث انطلق تعمله النسخه
السابعه والعشرين من مؤتمر المناخ وخلال
المؤتمر وافق المندوبون المشاركون على
مناقشه مساله تعويض الدول الفقيره الاكثر
عرضه للتضرر من تغير المناخ من قبل الدول
الغنيه تعقدوا هذه القمه على مدى 13 يوما
بحضور ممثلين دوله فيما يجتمع الرؤساء يوم
الاثنين والثلاثاء
رئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي اكد ضروره
انتقال قمه المناخ كوب 27 من مرحله الوعود
الى التنفيذ باجراءات الملموسه لانقاذ
الكوكب من الاخطار التي تحيط به واضاف في
تدوينه له تزامنا مع افتتاح قمه المناخ
انها تعقد في توقيت حساسه للغايه يتعرض
فيه العالم لاخطار الوجوديه وتحديات غير
مسبقه واشار الى ضروره ان يكون هناك تحرك
عالمي سريع لوضع خريطه طريق للانقاذ تحمل
العالم من تاثيرات التغيرات المناخيه
وخلال المؤتمر اكد وزير الخارجيه المصري
سامح شكري انا الوقت قد حان الانتقالي من
مرحله المفاوضات والتعاهدات الى مرحله
تدعو الى تنفيذ اتفاق برنامج عمل باريس
للمناخ
من المفاوضات والتعهدات الى مرحله يحظى
فيها التنفيذ بالاولويه
بتنفيذ ماترادين عليه في الاتفاقيه
الايطاليه لتغيير المناخ
وعززنا في اتفاق باريس وبرنامج العمل
الخاص به مع ضروره رفع مستوى الطموح لكل
الدول وفقا لقدراتها المتباينه
في شرم الشيخ غدا عقد نسخه الثانيه من قمه
مبادره الشرق الاوسط الاخضر بمشاركه واسعه
من رؤساء الدول والحكومات من منطقه الشرق
افريقيا اضافه الى المملكه المتحده
واليونان وكان ولي العهد السعودي الامير
محمد بن سلمان اعلن في وقت سابق عقد نسخه
الثانيه من مبادره الشرق الاوسط الاخضر
والسعوديه الخضراء في شرم الشيخ بالتزامن
مع مؤتمر المناخ
تنضم الينا من شرم الشيخ مراسله العربيه
رند ابو العزم رندا مرحبا بك كيف كان
اليوم الاول من المؤتمر حتى الان
بالاجتماعات وبالاجتماعات الثنائيه
ورش العمل انا اقف هنا في احد اللقاعات
التي تضم عدد كبير من الدول المشاركه
وخلفي همم
جناح المملكه العربيه السعوديه همم جناح
من اكبر الاجنحه لان كما ذكرت بتنطلق غدا
النسخه الثانيه من قمه الشرق الاوسط
الاخضر همم برعايه ولي العهد المملكه
العربيه السعوديه همم الامير محمد بن
سلمان وبحضور عدد كبير من القاده
المشاركين في الرابعه مساء
وايضا هناك عدد كبير من الدول يعني ب- ب-
امام جناحنا المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بنجاح ده جد جناح المانيا همم
الاتحاد الاوروبي همم مصر الامارات يعني
همم هناك فعاليات كثيره جدا عدد كبير من
النشطاء
بنجد همم وجدنا همم ناس من كل العالم همم
اعداد كبيره جدا مشاركه ونحن في المنطقه
الزرقاء هناك منطقه اخرى خضراء
بتجلس فيها منظمات المجتمع المدني ال- همم
منظمات التي تحافظ على البيئه همم
المبادرات المختلفه همم ولكن ربما بنعود
مره اخرى للتحديات امام هذا المؤتمر كاب
27 الذي يجيه واسطه اا ازمه اقتصاديه
عالميه واست- مشاكل سياسيه جيو سياسيه
بيخشى الكثيرون من ان ايه تنعكس على
مخرجات هذا المؤتمر كما ذكرت همم حان
الوقت لتنفيذ ما تم الاتفاق عليه يعني
هناك اتفاق حول 100 مليار دولار في قمه
كوبنهاجن عام 2009 وحتى الان لم يتم
التعهدات والتعهدات لابد من زيادتها
بزياده كبيره جدا ايضا الطاقه ازمه الطاقه
سلاسل الغذاء كيف يمكن التغلب على هذا خفض
الانبعاث الانبعاثات الكربونيه همم دول
العشرين الكبرى مسؤوله عن 85% من هذه
الانباتات الدول الناميه والدول الافريقيه
ليست مسؤوله عن هذا الحجم ولكنها تريد
تمويل لكي تتحول تكنولوجيه همم لمبادرات
همم يعني لا تضر بالبيئه وهذا يحتاج تمويل
في حدداته الان التحدي امام العالم هو همم
يعني هذا ليس طرفا همم عندما تحدثت كنت مع
همم وزير الخارجيه المصريه سامح شكري ربما
الاقرب هو الفيضانات التي رايناها في
باكستان التحول الكبير جدا في ال- ال-
الاجواء في العالم كله ما نشهده يتحكم
علينا العمل جميعا الدول المتقدمه والدول
الناميه جنبا الى جنب هذه هي اهم ربما
التحديات هل سيخرج هذا المؤتمر بالي
معينه يتم تنفيذها خلال العام القادم اا
قبل ان تتسلم الامارات من مصر هذا المؤتمر
همم طب 28 هذا هو السؤال الذي يطرح نفسه
ولكن قم يعني المشاركون والمستوى المشاركه
الذي وصل حتى هذه اللحظه هو يعني يوم
بالخير وربما بنجد مخرجات يتم تفعيلها
ايضا ذكرت خالد همم النسخه الثانيه من
قيمه الشرق الاوسط الخضراء همم برعايه سمو
ولي العهد همم ايضا سيتم الحديث فيها
لانها قمه بتعبر عن من الطموح الى العمل
همم بيتوقع منها الكثيرون وتتزامن مع هذه
القمه يجلس فيها عدد كبير من القاده في في
هذه الجلسه همم التي ستطلق غدا الانذار
بتتجه الى هذه القمه وهمم النسخه الثانيه
من القمه التي
يتعلق بهذه القمه همم
القادمه شكرا جزيلا لك من شرم الشيخ
مراسله العربيه رندا ابو الحسن
قبيل انتخابات التجديد النسبيه يوم
الثلاثاء نظم رئيس السابق دونالد ترامب او
انضم لتجمع الانتخابيه الجمهوريه في ولايه
بنسلفانيا لدعم مرشحي مجلس الشيوخ محمد
اوزود ماستريان والذي يرشح نفسه منصبه
حاكم الولايه
م تجمع صغير هنا لم يحضر احد لتجمعهم
انظروا الى هذا التجمع اعلنوا ان لديهم
تجمعا بخمسه الاف شخص لاوباما وبايت بدل
الامر وكانه حشد من 200 شخص
[موسيقى]
هذا وقود الجمهوريون معركه شرسه في مواجهه
المنافس
عادي مجلس الشيوخ وثمانيه تمكن من قلب
المعادله لمصلحته روان حمزه وتفاصيل
بمجلس النواب فيما تنتظرهم معركه شرسه
اثناء محاولتي قلبي مجلس الشيوخ لمصلحتهم
السيطره على مجلس الشيوخ تتوقف على ثلاث
ولايات هي جورجيا ونفاده وابن سلفانيا
الى اعاده انتخابهم في جورجيا في ما
يتنافس الحزبان على المقاعد في تنزيل
والذي كان يشغله الجمهوريه المتقاعد تومي
واي حزب سيفوز باثنين من الثلاثه مقاعد
ستزدادوا بقوه ليكون حزب الاغلبيه
وبحسب واشنطن بوستات
افضل فرصه للجمهوريين نظرا الى ان الحزب
الجمهوريه قدم ولي اول مره منذ سنوات مرشح
المعتدلا نسبيا هو المدعي العام السابق
ادم في جورجيا يحاول الجمهوريه
من السيناتور رافع الورد الذي حصل عليه
بجوله الاعاده العام الماضي في ما الامل
كبيره في بنسلفانيا بتمكن المرشح الجمهوري
محمد اوز من الفوز رغم استطلاعات الراي
التي اظهرت تخلفه عن جون فترمن
الديمقراطيه ولايه ويسكونسن تعد ثاني افضل
فرصه الديمقراطيين وتشهد تقدم لمرشحهم
مندل على السيناتور الجمهوريه
ايضا توجد فرصه جيده للديمقراطيين وفق
الاستطلاعات من نصيب المرشح ماركلي في
مواجهه المرشح المدعوم من ترامب ليك
ماسترز
[موسيقى]
رابع مستمره فيها بعد قليل
في الكويت لاعاده الحراك السياحيه في
البلد
اهلا بكم من جديد اكدت الهيئه السعوديه
للتخصصات الصحيه ضبطها عددا من الشهادات
التي اصدرتها الجامعه السودانيه الوهميه
قبل ان يتم كشف وهميه هذه الاكاديميه
الاسبوع الماضي
الشهادات لم يتمكنوا من اجتياز معايير
الهيئه في التدقيق
بعد اسبوع من الجدل الذي اثاره خبر القاء
القبض على رئيس جامعه سودانيه وهميه خرجت
خلال نحو عشر سنوات الاف الطلاب بمنحهم
شهادات مزوره من كلياتها التمريض والهندسه
والصيدله وغيرها جدلا قديم جديد يعود حول
الشهادات الوهميه وهل لاصحابها وجود على
راس العمل في السعوديه التي دخلت حربا لا
تزال قائمه ضد الشهادات المزوره واصحابها
منذ سنوات الهيئه السعوديه للتخصصات
الصحيه اكدت انها ضبطت عددا من الشهادات
التي اصدرتها الجامعه السودانيه الوهميه
حتى قبل ان يتم اكتشافه وهميتها لكن اصحاب
هذه الشهادات لم يتمكنوا من اجتياز معايير
الهيئه في التدقيق مؤكده انها تتبع
اجراءات دقيقه في التصنيف والتسجيل تمنع
دخول غير المؤهلين للقطاع الصحي خصوصا
القادمين من الخارج بحسب الهيئه الهيئه
اشاره ايضا الى ان اجراءات في قوى التاكد
من الشهادات تخضع للتدقيق قبل قدوم
الممارس الصحي للعمل حيث يتم التاكد من
صحه الشهادات قبل الشروع في تقديم طلبات
التصنيف ورغم ان الحرب على الشهادات
المزوره بدات فرديه عبر وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي منذ سنوات الا انها شهدت في
الاعوام الاخيره قبضه كبيره من ناحيه
الانظمه والقوانين التي تم فرضها ومنها
الاختبارات المهنيه حيث يتوجب على
الراغبين من خارج السعوديه بالعمل
اجتيازها خصوصا في هذه التخصصات الصحيه
والهندسيه والفنيه ما ضيق الخناقه على
حملتها الشهاده
ينضم لنفس فيديوهاتنا من الرياض المتحدث
الرسمي لهيئه التخصصات الصحيه في هذا
الكتاب حياك الله معك نشرته الرابع وشكرا
على التواجدك معنا
تواجد اليوم في نشره الرابعه خليني ابدا
معك من المؤكد انه انتم بعد الخبر درستوا
الموضوع ووصلتوا لعده نتائج او معلومات
الاسبوع الماضي في ما يتعلق بامتعه
يتخصصيات التعليق او اكد لك استاذ خالد
هيا تخصصات الصحيه لا تمتنع عن التعليق عن
اي موضوع او قضيه جاي التواصل جزء اساسي
من استراتيجيه
وهذا هو اساس عملنا في الحقيقه هو
الانفتاح على الاعلام والتواصل مع الزملاء
الاعلاميه في ما يتعلق بهذه القضيه انتشر
طبعا في وسائل التواصل لاعب وجود ممارسين
صحيين يعملون في القطاع الصحي في السعوديه
بعد تحقق الهيئه او بعد ما همم بحثنا في
البيانات خلصنا الى التعليم اولا اؤكد لك
لا يوجد ممارس صحي يحمل مؤهل من هذه
الجامعه الوهميه والاكاديميه الوهميه مسجل
في الهيئه السعوديه للتخصصات الصحيه
الثاني وجدنا اربع طلبات من تخصص التمريض
تقدمت الى الهيئه لكنها مجتهدت معايير
التصنيف او معايير همم الهيئه
هذا الامر
استدعاء الى انه نتاكد اكثر من ان هذه
المعايير طبقت على هذه الشهادات بالفعل لم
تجتاز قبل اكتشاف واهميه الجامعه
وبالمناسبه هي لم تقف اخي خالد يعني على
الاربعه الهيئه منذ انشائها هناك اكثر من
45,000 ممارس صحي اجنبي لم يستطيعوا
الدخول الى القطاع الصحي بسبب الاجراءات
التي تقوم فيها الهيئه السعوديه للتخصصات
الصحيه
اييي المبدع اللي قال مساله الامتناع وعدم
خلينا نتجاوز بتاكد لكنه دائما العربيات
تتخذ كل يعني
الطرق المهنيه في التواصل مع كل الجهات
ذات المسؤوليه او ذات العلاقه باي خبر
بعد الكلام اللي قلته انا افهم من كلامك
انه انت تؤكد لي بدرجه 100% عدم وجود اي
ممارس صحي حاصل على هذه الشهاده
الاكاديميه اللي تم الاعلان على انها
اكاديميه او جامعه وهميه هذا ما فهمتهم
منه طيب احنا في التقرير ما اظهر لنا بعض
الاسماء او بعض
الصفحات بمعرفات على انه حاصل من هذه على
شهاده من هذه الاكاديميين وهو موجود في
الرياض على سبيل المثال او في الدمام كما
يظهر له في الاسبوع الماضي من خلال
التقرير
هذا يعني كيف يعني نفهم انه ما في اي احد
حصل على هذه الشهاده لشرط دخوله الى
المملكه تحت عمل ممارس صحي والنجد انه
ممكن يكون موجود يعمل في قطاع صحي او في
مجازر
لا يمكن اليوم على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي التحقق والتاكد من هذا الشخص
يعمل في المملكه او يعني وسائل التواصل
اجتماعي يقرا فيها من المعلومات ما يقرا
وقد تكون حقيقه وقد تكون غير حقيقيه لكن
انا اؤكد لك انه لا يوجد احد مسجل في
الهيئه السعوديه لتخصصات الصحيه النظام في
المملكه لا يجيز لاي ممارس لا يجيز لاي
ممارس العمل في القطعه الصحي الا يكون
حاملا تسجيل الهيئه السعوديه تخصصات
الصحيه ولو كان موجود يعمل كم ممارس صحي
القطاع الخاص والقطاع ال- ال- هذا كيف
ممكن تفسيره طبعا هناك همم جهات مسانده
همم او جهات تتكامل معها مثل اداره
الالتزام في وزاره الصحه تقوم بالتاكد من
المنشات الطبيه والتاكد والتحقق من
ان الممارسين الصحيين يحملون
مثلا احنا ما نقدر نوكد
لكن كيف ممكن تفسير وجود ممارس صحي يعمل
في واحد من القطاعات الصحيه وفي منشاه
الصحيه في القطاع الخاص او الحكومي العام
وهو حاصل على هذا الشهر لا يمكن تفسير
عليه سياق لا يمكن تفسيره لان النظام في
المملكه لا يجوز عمل الممارس في القطاع
الصحي بدون تسجيل وبالتالي قد يدعي هناك
اشخاص قد يدعون مساله همم
املهم في القطاع الصحي لكن هم في الحقيقه
لا يعملوه في القطاع الصحيحي شخص قد يظهر
شخص على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي لكن
الهيئه معايير الهيئه انتم ما بتقدروا فقط
انه لا يمكن ان يعمل احد في كمرس صحي الا
بعد مروره بالاجراءات اللي هي من ضمن
الاختبارات
في اي قطاع الا لما يكون في عمليه الضبط
هناك اداره وزاره الصحه بالتعاون مع
الجهات الامنيه بالتعاون بالتكامل مع جهات
اخرى
لا يمكن التحقق الا بالضبط
لا يمكن ولا يستطيع ان يشغل ممارس صحي
بدون تسجيل هذه التخصصات الصحيه واذا
صاروا انهم شغالين
طبعا انت لا تستطيع ان تحكم
المنشات المخالفه هناك منشات قد تكون هناك
منشات مخالفه اخذ قد تكون هناك منشات
مخالفه قد يكون هناك همم خلل لكن في امر
معين بعيدا عن موضوع الرقابه ولكن اليوم
لا يمكن ان تجزم حقيقه احنا نتحدث الان عن
افتراضات لا يمكن ان تجزم حقيقه انه هناك
ممارسه الصحه يحمل او لا يحمل مؤهل يعمل
في القطاع لا يمكن لا يمكن لانه لا يمكن
لانه لا يوجد لا يوجد جلاتكم
ينتمي او حاصل على شهاده هذه الاكاديميه
الوهميه اللي طلعت
وموجود او حصل على اجازه من هيئه التخصصات
الصحيه اللي تخوله للعمل كم ممارسه الصحيه
يجب ان تقوم بالمتابعه عليه سميتها باداره
الاتزان تابعه لوزاره السعوديه
هي دورها تقوم بالتاكد من مؤهلات هذا
الممارس الصحي التاكد من معايير الخبره
التاكد من جميع الخبرات التي يتقدم فيها
للهيئه لا وبعد ذلك اجتاز كل المعايير ثم
تاتي مرحله الاختبارات طبعا اخي خالد احنا
نقوم بهذه الاجراءات جميعها لسبب واحد فقط
هو المحافظه على مامونيه الممارسه
المحافظه على مامونيه القطاع الصحي وسلامه
الناس وسلامه الناس اولويه مهمه عندنا كيف
انتم همم
معاييركم او اجراءاتكم المتبعه اللي همم
العاملين من الخارج اللجوء للعمل في
القطاع الصحي مش اهم هذه الاجراءات التي
وصول الممارسه الصحي قبل وصول المملكه اول
شيء نتاكد من الشهاده هل هي صحيحه وغير
صحيحه طبعا الهيئه تعمله بشكل محلي وتعمل
مع شريك على مستوى الدولي وكيف تتاكدوا ان
الشهاده الصحيه وغير صحيحه يعني
لا هو يتقدم بطلب
ومعيار توفيق الشهاده هو جزء من معايير
الهيئه معيار توفيق الشهاده هو جزء من
وزاره الخارجيه مثلا عن توفيق وزاره
الخارجيه الهيئه لديها شريك عالمي تقوم
بالتاكد من الشهادات ثم تخضع هذه الشهادات
للتدقيق الداخلي في هيئه التخصصات الصحيه
ثم نتاكد من ان هذا الممارس لديه خبره
مزاوله او شهاده او رخصه مزاوله في بلده
ثم نعمل له الاختبارات اللازم للتاكد من
كفاء يعني افهم من كلامك حتى نتاكد اليوم
من وجود او عدم وجود ممارسه صحيحيه حاصل
على هذه الشهاده اللي اعلن على انها شهاده
لاكاديميه وهميه حسب السلطات السودانيه
الدور هنا يكون على اداره الالتزام في
وزاره الصحه
كتله كيف اخي خالد واكد لك ما تاكد للساده
المشاهدين انت تقول انا انا اجراءات ما في
احد ممكن يعمل الا بنائه لكنك تقول لي انا
ما اقدر ااكد لك عدم وجود ناس يعملوا في
هذا القطار قد يكون مخالفين طبعا هذا دور
جهات اخرى في التفتيش والتاكد لا يمكن حتى
الا بالضبط التاكد من خلال هذه الاداره
المفروض تقوم بدور التفتيش والرقه والتاكد
من وجود حالات هو ان يكون بالضبط لكن
بالضبط غير موجود يعني هي مجرد صفحات على
الانترنت تدعي انها تعمل في السعوديه قد
تكون حقيقه لا تكون حقيقه يعني انا اشكرك
على تواجدك وعلى تجاوبك على هذه يعني
المعلومات
والتاكيدات اللي همم وكذلك يعني ان شاء
الله يكون في كذلك تجاوب من خلال هذه
الحياه المهندسين وكذلك ننتظر ان يكون
هناك تجاوب ايضا من همم ربما اداره
الالتزام اللي تؤكد وتنفي هذه القصه شكرا
جزيلا لك في هذه الكتابه متحدث الرسمي
نهايته التخصصات الصحيه شكرا
السعوديه اعلنت المؤسسه العامه لتحليه
المياه ان شاء الله اول مصنع في الشرق
الاوسط لصناعه اغشيه التنابح العكسي مع
هيئه المحتوى
المحليه والمشتريات الحكوميه وشركه تواريخ
الشرق الاوسط التي تعدل الذي يعد الاول من
نوعه التناضح العكسي الذي يتم بكامل
مراحله
مع اعلان مؤسسه المياه عن توقيع عددا من
الاتفاقيات مع الشركات محليه وعالميه في
تقنيات المياه
نتكلم عن عدد من المصانع في سنبدا ااا
ابتداء من المصنع تنضح العكسي هذا المصنع
يكون بالشراكه من شركه توري اليابانيه
الهدف من هذا المصنع هو العمل المشترك ااا
بين المؤسسه والمصنعين والمستثمر المحلي
ااا في ايجاد فرص افضل لاطاله العمر
الافتراضي التشغليلي
الاغشيه تناضح العكسي خفض استهلاك الطاقه
همم المصنع اليوم بمواصفات الابتدائيه
اللي وقعنا عليها يلبي اعلى مواصفات
الاغشيه التي تقودها المؤسسه في طلباتها
لصناعه التحليليه مثل هذا المصنع سيساهم
في همم ميزان التجاري المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بما يعادل 135 مليون ابتداء من
العام 20 25 همم مثل هذا المصنع خلال خمس
سنوات الاولى من عمله سيساهم في زياده
الناتج المحلي الى مليار و140 مليون همم
لنا نعلم ان اليوم الطلب التغطيه في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه سوق الاقصيه في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه يبلغ 50 و70,000
غشاء سنويا وسيبلغ مليون غشاء في حلول عام
في الكويت من المقرر ان تنطلق قريبا
المنصه السياحيه اكتشف في الكويت وذلك ضمن
مساءا الى اعاده الحراك السياحيه في
البلاد
وستشكل المنصه بدورها منطلقا لتفعيل
المهرجانات والفعاليات الترفيهيه في
الكويت ترتيب الجهود تقوم بها الجمعيه
الكويتيه للمهرجانات التي ذكرت في
التفاصيل ان العمل على مشروع نكتشف الكويت
ستكون نقطه انطلاق لتنشيط القطاع السياحي
هي موجهه حاليا الى مواطنين الدول المسموح
لهم بدخول الكويت على راسها دول مجلس
التعاون الخليجي
رابعه مستمره في بعد قليل
استعداداتهم صحيه متكامله لاستقبال
الجماهير كاس العالم في الاحساء الشرقيه
السعوديه
عن اقتراع النصفي وترامب يحطون الناخبين
على التصويت بكثافه
جدول واسع حول جامعه سودانيه غضبت شهادات
مزيفه في تخصصات صحيه في السعوديه
شركه عالميه واقليميه غالبيتها الصحيه
وشركات كوريا الجنوبيه تبدا بجوله في
الرياض لبحث الفرص الاستثماريه في النقل
والابتكار
اهلا بكم من جديد طلبوا كبير لا زال
يتصاعد على سوق المكاتب الفاخره في الرياض
يتزامن مع افتتاحات شركات عالميه لمقراتها
في الرياض لازم فالي احد المشاريع
العقاريه التي جذبت العديد من الشركات
الطبيه ليصبح قريه طبيه مصغره في العاصمه
الرياض
اصبح هذا المشهد الاحتفالي في مدينه
الرياض خلال الاشهر الماضيه اعتياديا نظرا
لكثره نقل الشركات العالميه مقراتها
وافتتاح مكاتب لها في العاصمه ما جعله
هنالك الطلب عالي على سوق المكاتب لا سيما
من فئه الف
[موسيقى]
على ايقاع العرضه النجديه يحتفل رئيس
التنفيذي لشركه الادويه السويسريه روج
بافتتاح مقر شركه
بحضور وزير الاستثمار خالد الفالح في لاسم
ثاني حيث تجتمع اكثر من 50 شركه عالميه
واقليميه
غالبيتها في القطاع الطبي اهميه الانتقال
للعاصمه للرياض وافتتاح المكتب
في وسط الرياض اليوم له اهميه لشركه رشا
اليوم واعطاء الرساله الواضحه همم باهميه
والاستثمار بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه
لحتى همم هل انوفيشن والابتكارات الجديده
اللي همم بتطلع من رش تكون موجوده باثر
على وقت للمرضى سميت المنطقه التي كذبت
الشركات الدوليه بالاسم ثاني تيامنا باسم
وادي الشهير الذي اصبح تحفه معماريه في
قلب الرياض اتخذته الشركات الطبيه هو
المستشفيات مقر لها على مساحه 1500 متر
مربع اخترنا هذا الموقع همم للاكسس
سبيليتي او الوصول السهل فيها شفنا انه
المكان هذا ممكن يكون قريب من شركائنا من
المستشفيات ومن الوزارات والوصول له بشكل
افضل وكذلك المجمع يوفر بيئه جميله
للموظفين يوفر خدمات جميله للموظفين وشفنا
انه قد يكون هذا افضل مكان نحط فيه المكتب
الرئيسي والحمد لله اتوقع انه توفقنا فيه
الطلب لا زال يتصاعدوا على قطاع المكاتب
الفاخره بعد انعام خلال السنوات الماضيه
من عكس على جوده المشاريع مثل وادي الليثى
الذي يتوقع ان يصبح رافدا اقتصاديا لمدينه
الرياض عبد المحسن الحربي العربي الرياض
استعاده التجمع الصحي في محافظه الاحساء
في شرق السعوديه لاستقبال الاف المشجعين
القادمين والمتجهين من والى مونديال قطر
لكاس العالم وذلك عبر خطه المتكامله
وضعتها وزاره الصحه السعوديه بالتعاون مع
جهه الحكوميه الاخرى حيث حدد التجمع الصحي
بالاحساء عددا من المستشفيات للتعامل مع
مشجعين كاس العالم ورفع الجهازيه فيها
اضافه الى تجهيز عدد من مراكز الرعايه
الصحيه بعيادتي
بعياده رعايه عاجلا متوسطه الخطوره وقليله
الخطوره
مستشفى الملك فيصل العام في الاحصاء ينضم
الينا مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيميه
اهلا عبد الرحمن
الاستعدادات الان الى اي مرحله وصلت
الاستعدادات على قدم وساق ليس فقط في
القطاع الصحيح خالد بالجميع القطاعات غدا
سيكون لدينا لقاء مع سمو محافظ مدينه
الاحساء ومحافظه الاحساء الحديث اكثر عن
المشاريع السياحيه الامانه ايضا القطاعات
الامنيه وعلى راسها ايضا القطاعات الصحيه
التي طبعا
تتشارك مع كثير من القطاعات وهي على
اولويات همم الحكومه السعوديه دائما وابدا
الحديث اكثر عن هذه الاستعداد تحديدا خالد
ينضم الي نائب رئيس التنفيذي للتشغيل في
تجمع الاحساء المهندس عبد الله البشر
ساعات المهندس اولا متى وكيف استعديت ل
همم كاس العالم واستقبال المشجعين حياك
الله اخوي عبد الرحمن واشكر تلفزيون
العربيه على استضافتنا الابراج جهود تجمع
الاحساس الصحي وزي ما تفضلت في المقدمه
حقيقه الحدث الكبير يتطلب كثير من الجهود
لتاكد من همم سلامه زوار والجما هي خصوصا
للمنتخب الوطني مشارك في هذا المونديال
نتمنى على التوفيق
وتم الاعداد
للاستعداد لهذا الحدث من عده اشهر حقيقه
همم حيث تم تشكيل لجنه بدعم من مقام
الوزاره همم تتكون من تجمع المنطقه
الشرقيه
والزملاء في شؤون الهندسه
في مستشفى الملك فيصل هو احد المستشفيات
التي ستستقبل اي حاله طارئه او اي حاله
مصابه من مشجعين قدر الله او تعرض صحي
طبعا متاحه للخدمه على مدار الساعه همم
وزي ما ذكر قبل شوي تم تشكيل لجنه هذه
عملها تاكد من توفر الخدمات الطبيه همم في
المناف هل تم تحديد مستشفيات خاصه مراكز
صحيه خاصه للتعامل مع اشجع كاس العالم
هلا كنت تم تحديد مستشفى العمران نظرا
لموقع الجغرافي للقرب من الطرق الدوليه
المؤديه الى دوله قطر
وتاكد من جاهزيه طواقم الطبيه والخدمات
المسانده وجميع الخدمات في المستشفى في
الطوارئ والمراكز الصحيه اضافه الى ذلك
يوجد مستشفى الملك فهد وهو مستشفى
المرجعيه في المحافظه تم التاكد من جهز
جاهزيتها في حال وجود اي حالات تحتاج تدخل
تخصصيه يتم تحويلها للمستشفى ان شاء الله
عن سلوى تقريبا 200 كيلو واغلب المشجعين
جزء منهم هيروح بالسيارات في حال حدوث
حادث مروري الى قدر الله كيف حيث يتم
التعامل مع هذه الحوادث سلامه الطرق
الحقيقيه من اهم المحاور اللي تم التجهيز
لها يوجد في محافظه الاحساء ست فرق
اسعافيه على مدار الساعه متواجده تم
مراعاه ومواقعها لتكون قريبه من طرق
الدوليه اضافه الى ما سيتم توفيرها على
الطرق الاخرى همم على مستوى المنطقه
الشرقيه همم تم بالتنسيق مع الهلال الاحمر
لتوفير خدمه ال- همم الاسعاف الطائر يوجد
طائره متواجده في مطار هيليكوبتر
متواجده في مطار الاحساء وطائره متواجده
في مطار الدمام لولا سمح الله استودع
الامر تدخل همم في مثل هذا الجانب شكرا
جزيلا المهندس عبد الله يعطيك العافيه
خالد يعني كما راينا هنا في مستشفى الملك
فيصل هو احد المستشفيات التي ستستقبل اي
حاله لقدر الله من مشجعين او حتى السياح
القادمين من قطر او الذاهبين الى قطر وعدد
كبير من المراكز الصحيه ايضا في همم في
محافظه الاحساء يعطيك العافيه شكرا جزيلا
لك عبد الرحمن العصيمي مراسل العربيه من
الاحسن
اليوم في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض اولى
الجولات التاريخيه السعوديه الكوريه للنقل
والابتكار بحضور وزير النقل والخدمات
اللوجستيه السعوديه ووزير الاراضي والبنيه
التحتيه والنقل لدى كوريا الجنوبيه
ومجموعه من المستثمرين في القطاع الخاص في
الجانب الكوري حيث جرى استعراض الفرس
والمبادرات الكبرى ومجلات الاستثمار في
قطاع النقل والخدمات اللوجستيه في
السعوديه
وزير النقل والخدمات اللوجستيه السعودي
صالح الجسر اوضح انه بحث مع الجانب الكوري
حول فرص التعاون المشترك في مجالات منها
التقنيه
اليوم عقد الجوله التعريفيه اللي فيها عدد
من الشركات ذات العلاقه بالبنيه التحتيه
وخدمات النقل والابتكار عرضت ما لديها
ايضا قمنا بعرض
الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه للنقل والخدمات
اللوجستيه وتم التباحث على فرص التعاون
المشتركه بين البلدين كما نعلم كوريا من
الدول المتقدمه في البنيه التحتيه وفي
التقنيات النقل والتقنيات الحديثه
كده وزير الاراضي والبنيه التحتيه والنقل
لدى كوريا الجنوبيه
ان تكون شركه في تحقيق اهداف رؤيه
السعوديه 2030
خلال هذه الجوله التعريفيه عرضنا
التكنولوجيا المتطوره التي تملكها الشركات
الكوريه كما ان من بين المشاركين جهات
حكوميه واخرى تمويليه حيث نعمل ان نساهم
في تحقيق اهداف رؤيه 20 30 اضافه الى
الخطه التنمويه للسعوديه اطلعنا خلال هذه
الجوله على ما يمكن ان نساهم به ونجد ان
بامكاننا النجاح بالتعاون معا في مجالات
عده منها النقل والابتكار
اه اه
ضمن اعمال مؤتمر المحاكاه الصحيه للمنعقده
في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض كشف مدير مركز
الاسنان الطبيعي المشترك للقوات المشتركه
العميد عن الكناني في حديث العربيه كشف عن
سعي مركز الاسناد الطبي الى تعزيز وتطوير
عمليات الرعايه الصحيه المقدمه للجنود
والعاملين في ميادين القتال تابعه للقوات
المشتركه
المؤتمر المحاكاه الصحيه في الرياض مراسل
العربيه نواف
حدثنا اكثر عن هذا الموسم
نعم خالد قبل قليل اختتمت اعمال اليوم
الاول من مؤتمر المحاكاه الصحيه في نسخته
الخامسه والذي يعود بعد انقطاع دام لي
عامين متتاليين بسبب جائتكورونا منذ بدايه
اليوم الاول العديد من الجهات الحكوميه
المدنيه والعسكريه تواجدت في المؤتمر
تستعرض من خلال هذا المؤتمر العديد من
الفرضيات التي تتم بشكل مباشر امام زوار
المؤتمر وايضا المشاركين لمحاكاه واقع ايه
ايه يفترض ان يحدث في ميادين القتال او في
المستشفيات او في اقسام الطوارق والتعامل
معها بطريقه همم مبتكره ومنظمه ايضا ويتم
هذا امام الطلبه والمشاركين من مختلف دول
العالم هذا بالاضافه الى العديد من
الجلسات الحواريه التي يقدمها اكثر من 50
متحدث دولي تفاصيل اكثر عن هذا المؤتمر
ينضم احمد الفهيد رئيس اللجنه المنظمه في
هذا المؤتمر اهلا وسهلا بك سيد احمد في
البدايه كيف كانت المجريات في اليوم الاول
اهلا وسهلا وحياكم الله قناه العربيه ولله
الحمد والمنه اليوم الاول حفل بكثير من
التفاعل من العديد من الجهات كما اشرتم
همم يحظى بمشاركه واسعه محليا ودوليا ال-
همم الشركائنا من جميع القطاعات الحكوميه
وكذلك الخاصه همم اسهموا مساهمه فاعله في
همم زياده الجاذبيه المؤتمر في زياده همم
الحافز لحضور كثير من الانشطه العديد من
ورش العمل العديد من البرامج همم
التدريبيه همم شركانا يعني كمان شهد خلفنا
الان في القطاع العسكري همم نفذوا فرضيات
همم متعدده في مجال همم المحاكاه المحاكاه
الطب العسكري الميداني محاكاه الاصابات
همم واخرها عدد من الفرضيات اللي يق فيها
تتولى همم ايصال همم او محاكاه الواقع في
همم ميادين العز والشرف همم للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه والجنودها البواسل كذلك
القطاعات الاخرى ايضا ساهمت بزياده همم
المواد التعليميه والتعريفيه حضينا ولله
الحمد والمنه ايضا بمشاركه دوليه غير
مسبوقه حيث تم اقرار المؤتمر من ثمان جهات
دوليه معتمده لبرامج المحاكاه مشاركه
واسعه ايضا من همم المتحدثين الدوليين من
رؤساء كثير من الجهات اللي وصلوا لله
الحمد لله المملكه مقاعد المؤتمر همم
الخاصه بالورش العمل ومقاعد المؤتمر لحضور
الجلسات العلميه همم تم شغلها بالكامل لله
الحمد لله كل الشكر لك همم احمد الفهيد
رئيس اللجنه المنظمه لهذا المؤتمر اذا
خالد همم نضيف الى ذلك الى ان همم الطلبه
والمهتمين يمكنهم الاستفاده من المؤتمر من
خلال ساعات تدريبيه 160 ساعه تدريبيه على
مدى خمسه ايام وهي ايام المؤتمر همم
ودراسه العديد من همم المجالات الطبيه ضمن
برنامج تعليمي طبي مستمر طوال ايام هذا
المؤتمر
العربيه الصحيه
بعضهم البعض باحترام
حيث قيمه في مرسول بار في العاصمه الرياضه
بحضور سته من افضل دبليو دبليو
بالحماس والاعجاب استقبل عشرات الاطفال
ابطال المصارعه السته الذين شاركوا في
فعاليه بيس ستار لتعزيز التعلم العاطفي
ومكافحه التنمر حيث امتزجت القوه بالرسائل
التوعويه لرفض التنمر
وخارجها بين الجماهير حيث نعامل بعضنا
البعض باحترام
موسم الرياضه رحب بالمشاهير المصارعين
لنقل قصصهم حول التنمر ومواجهتهم له عبر
ترديد كلمه كون نجما ولا تكن متنمرا
فالتفاعل مع الاطفال زاد من الرغبه
بالاستمرار في نقل تلك الرساله في كل دول
العالم
يوضح لهم اهميه الاحترام وان لا يكون
متنمرين وكيفيه التفاعل فيما بينهم بلطف
هذه المنصه مفيده جدا وانا عارف الشعور
بالتنمر وهو سيء فامنا مفيده موضح لهم
كيفيه الاستمتاع بالحياه بايجابيه انه
لشرفا نتمكن من فعل ذلك
بكذلك تعتقد بان هذا الامر مفيد جدا لان
الكثير من الاطفال يتابعون المصارعه
العالميه الحره وانا اعرف بان بعض
شخصياتنا تحومها بعض التساؤلات لذلك من
المهم جدا ان ناتي الى هناك وان نوضح لهم
بانهم في الحياه الحقيقيه من المهم جدا
نعامل الاخرين كما نحب ان يعاملونا اي
باحترام
قرر ابطال المصارعه استغلال قوتهم الجسديه
واعجاب الاطفال بهم للمره الثالثه خلال
مواسم الرياضه في التاكيد عليهم بان القوه
احيانا تكون في اللطف مع الاخرين
من الرياض شهد متروك العربيه
على بدايه هبوب الرياح الشماليه البارده
تقويم مع خالد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كله له طريقته الخاصه في حساب الفصولي
والمواسم يختلفون في الاليات ويتفقون في
النتائج واهم النجوم الحسابيه عند الباديه
والحاضره سهيل ليش لان ظهوره وخفائه مرتبط
بالتغيرات المناخيه والسلوكيات الزراعيه
واهم من نجوم الحسابيه عند البحاره الحيمر
لان ظهوره وخفائه ايضا مرتبط بالسلوكيات
المائيه بين قوسين البحر سمي بهذا لانه
نجم صغير احمر مثل النقطه ويسمى عند العرب
القدماء بالقلب فهو يقع وسط برج العقرب
فهو بمثابه القلب سلى القلب عما كان يهوى
ويطلبه واصبح لا يشكوه ولا يتعتبوا الى كم
اداري من تريد مذلتي وابذل جهد في رضاها
وتغضب شكر الله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وخلال هذه الايام يغيب نجمه لحيمر مع مغيب
الشمس وهذا اماره وعلامه على بدايه هبوب
الرياح الشماليه المشوبه بالبروده كمقدمات
الحالات الشتويه القادمه تتخلق الحالات
المداريه والتي ربما تتحول الى اعاصير في
بحر العرب ولهذا يسميها البحاره بضربه
لحيمر كان الرياح تضرب السفن الخشبيه
فتغرقها ومده الخفاء اربعين يوما ومعظهوره
كره ثانيه يدخل علينا النجم الثاني من
النجوم المربعانيه اذا طلع القلب جاء
الشتاء كالكلب واصبح اهل البوادي
في كرب
[موسيقى]
ختام الرابعه بالعناوي
مؤتمر شرم الشيخ للمناخ ينطلق تاكيد على
الحلول العاجله في مواجهه التغيرات
المناخيه
يوم ان تفصل الولايات المتحده عن الاقتراع
النصفي وترامب بحوث الناخبين على التصويت
بكثافه
[تصفيق]
جدول واسع حول جامعه سودانيه وهميه وضبط
شهاده المزيفه في تخصصات صحيه في السعوديه
الرابعه تتجول في لسان فالي وادي يجمع
اكثر من 50 شركه عالميه واقليميه
غالبيهتها شركات صحيه
شركات كوريا الجنوبيه تبدا جوله في الرياض
لبحث الفرص الاستثماريه في مجالات النقل
والابتكار
[موسيقى]